I'm very happy to see everybody today
and I am Eugenia and I will talk about
our library created a toloka crowd kit
and we will of course go through it
slowly with right amount of
understanding like why this library is
even needed what are crowdsourced
annotations why we're referring to
scikit-learn and like what is it all
about
so let's start with a problem that we
are trying to solve having this library
and let's a little bit begin in this
world of crowdsourced annotations
so imagine
uh or you don't have even to imagine
that that you're a machine learning
engineer and uh or you're just a big
company or not even a big company and
you're having a problem of uh you want
to have some machine learning solution
but you don't have data for it for
example you're an app you have negative
and positive reviews in app store and
there are so many that you need to
classify them beforehand to pay
attention only at valuable negative ones
to create some corrections to your
product and make it better and of course
you want to do it automatically but for
that for learning machine learning
algorithm for example you need some data
some reviews previously classified for
you or even more interesting task let's
imagine you're a self-driving card
architect and you want to train your car
how to operate in a city but before like
getting it out to operate with the real
humans and everything you would prefer
it to being trained to very well
distinguished between like road signs
between red and green light and like
between humans and like I don't know
some lights
so you need to get a data you need to
get a data set labeled and of course
there are like a lot of options for that
uh synthetic data finding them in open
source but usually uh domains are pretty
much uncovered so for data set labeling
you need somebody to do it manually and
when it comes to manual labeling
sometimes people are like having experts
in their companies for labeling and
they're paying them some money and it's
also an option but usually in machine
learning you need like a big piles of
data and here comes one of the options
how to gather this data which is
crowdsourcing
just imagine that you're having some
platform uh where you can like register
your task decompose it and send it to
like a thousand thousand thousands of
humans for example you want to gather
the data set of pictures and like you're
giving like one annotator one picture
and asking to give some result on this
picture
of course when I have thousands of
people working with your data you pretty
much can be sure that it's scalable and
you will have like a big amount of data
as a result but the problem is
quality of data like here you are not
sure in anything when you're working
with your home expert
it's understandable that the result will
be very good but if you are working with
somebody who haven't signed a contract
or anything you don't know that the
result will be high quality and here
comes a very simple technique
how to ensure uh quality in your data
which comes from the phrase that two
heads are better than one when you're
giving it to crowdsourcing you better
like check opinions of the crowds and
the different data labeled and gathered
with the multiple different people not
meeting each other so for example you
give them one picture to three people
and you ask them to give some result
like some hello world problem of uh
crowdsourcing science like tell me is it
a cat or a dog
okay so you have now a huge tons of raw
data and you need somehow to get still
one label out of it and here comes the
other question like we're solving one
problem we're having another problem
coming at us how to aggregate it how to
get the final result which is high
quality and good enough for our models
for our production for everything
and pretty much
um natural way which like I guess
everybody of you will guess it it's easy
to understand when you're like giving
some information some factor multiple
crowd of people and they're giving for
example like categorical answers like
yes or no
the overall answer is just the maturity
rule you're like saying okay these two
said yes this one said no I will listen
to less of a people uh so yeah that was
like the simplest idea of aggregation
with categorical that
then let's imagine that you had some
knowledge about the data labeled and you
need some ground truth answers and you
evaluated post factum answers of this
crowd and you realize that one person is
giving answers in 19 of the cases
correct and other in 50 and you're like
okay why would I even listen to the one
who gives answer in a 50 of the case is
incorrect
so you're evaluating this you're using
this overall scale estimated quality of
a person and you're creating boom a
weighted majority rule and still like
you'll listen to me now and they're like
okay I'm in a pie data conference I know
how to write one liner which does this
and I don't need any library and I will
pretty much agree with you but when it
comes to crowdsourcing the Beautiful
part of it that any type of a data can
be gathered with a cloud of annotators
for example it can be pairwise
comparisons let's say you have
interfaces and you want to like make
your app looking better so you're asking
people what is better like interface a
or interface B and here you can also ask
multiple people but the answer is pretty
much subjective so here when it comes to
aggregation you need to think of
something more smart than just doing a
majority rule or imagine you have a
sexual responses you're Gathering
captions for your images to train some
image to text big model and people are
answering pretty much the same but with
some difference in letters in like
articles or something
you can try to do a majority world over
letters but it still sounds not like as
simple to do and it's fast to do and
even when it comes to images and
segmentations also you can solve this
task with for example like pixel wise
majority world but still very hard
you are not sure that it will work fast
it's not easy to write and here comes
crowdkit and we created crowdkit as a
data science Library which will be very
easy to start using for people who
already work with such machine learning
libraries as numpy CPI or especially
psychic learn the one that I used for my
title and uh why why we try to do that
because data sets Gathering is one of
the big parts of the machine learning
pipeline so I really want any engineer
working with a hollower machine learning
pipeline in Python being able to open in
in any Library knowing already how in
general they work and which methods in
general they have and not having to
study from the beginning some of the
documentation of some new library
so we tried while building our crowd kit
to base it on the same principles of API
as scikit-learn based and let me a
little bit like discuss that their
consistency which was I guess pretty
well known for engineers it's like in
every element of the interface every
interface is implemented consistently
with a limited amount of methods and
like performs as expected so in
different parts of a system you have the
same outcome it's inspection so we have
these black boxes in scikit-learn
machine learning algorithms which are
getting learned by some parameters and
then they are doing predictions on some
data and all of these parameters
gathered through learning and
predictions there can be accessed by a
user everything should be transparent
the same is in crowdkit with its black
boxes and its aggregation algorithms
it's non-proliferation of classes you're
not complicating your code you're
creating specific interfaces only for
your black boxes or learning algorithms
or aggregating algorithms its
composition every machine learner and I
guess every engineer understands that
every system is built from the basic
building blocks so you should be able to
access them and combine them in
different ways to create more complex
Pipelines
and finally it's sensible defaults so
when you're creating your black box
algorithm sometimes you don't want to
like toggle to every micro parameter for
example like how many times you look at
your input data or something so defaults
which are selected should work
moderately good so we did the same
and I to make a good comparison of crowd
kit and explain why it's simple to use
if you are an engineer which worked
already with all data science libraries
I want to give a small small recap for
people maybe who haven't used it that
much or for some time to understand the
parallels that I will try to draw
so
psychic learn has
interface design which consists of three
interfaces and the first major one is
estimator which has a fit method to
explain it very simply is just you have
like a big container a black box like an
algorithm machine learning algorithm
which is being learned and it's firstly
instantiated with the sum parameters
which are crucial for this particular
algorithm and then separately it's being
learned on data so you have a data on
which you learn some patterns and then
you can predict results on unseen data
that's how technically machine learning
works and it's based on the partial
function application idea as you can see
here on the small sketch it's when
you're freezing a function with already
some parameters and then you're passing
it by
so estimators are more about learning
predictors it's an extension of
estimator interface which can predict
already on unseen data algorithm learns
and then it predicts the results
and also they have Transformers which
transform data
so as input what is like the beauty of
this machine learning libraries you
pretty much can put in anything that you
want any data and get an output which
will already like give some predictions
which are crucial to you in very
different tasks so data should be in
Matrix format and it doesn't matter how
many rows or columns do you have in this
Matrix and you can use pretty much
everything like numpy's key pipanders or
whatever
and here is an example how does it look
and here you can exactly pay attention
to the last lines when it's like just
instantiating an algorithm which is
linear regression here and then just
running and running a simple like
learning procedure with fit and
predicting so you're not doing something
as a rocket science you're just calling
to methods and we try to do the same we
try to build you know the same
principles as I said to make machine
learning pipelines as much smooth as
possible and add in our part with the
data Centric eye
so interfaces we created basically the
same idea of predictors that are in
scikit-learn but the difference with
crowdsource annotations that methods
very much differ based on the data type
that you're working with so for example
if classification requires like
aggregating which can be based on some
prior knowledge about the label and
we're thinking that it's pretty much
objective so there is actually a true
label to this data then for example
pairwise aggregations when you're like
saying what is better there is only
subjective knowledge so we can't use any
label prior knowledge we doesn't know
what is actually better in this pairwise
comparison so we're using other models
so here you can see five types of
interfaces
based on the data annotated type but
they're using the same methods which are
available known for a data scientists
which are fit and predict that's why I'm
saying that we have the same idea as
predictors since I could learn so you
can the same way call learning
co-predicting and the same way of
decoupling the interface or your first
instantiation
performance instantiation of your basic
aggregator and then you're like feeding
to it any type of crowdsources data
Cloud kit is platform agnostic and
receiving the result
as an input it's also used as pandas so
it uses a very well known Library you
don't need to find out about some
complex new data type that you never
seen in your life the one difference
with the scikit-learn here it's very
important what amount of columns do you
have in your Matrix data because for
using and crowdsourcing aggregation you
need to know who labeled what and how so
for that you have to specify columns
which for example numpy can do in the
end however it works pretty much the
same
and I will I wanna to present an example
of how crowdkit works and so here we're
taking a very well known data set with
ranking of complexity of two texts
passage a and passage B this is exactly
the pairwise comparison and we wanted to
test how crowdsourced annotations are
working on it so we are taking these two
passages this gathered data set and we
are going it through the crowdsourcing
labeling separately
and we're checking uh like this labeling
how it's happening what crowd is
choosing what is more hard to read
that's a j or passage B here you can see
the results of labeling the worker who
did it left and right passage and the
result what was more complicated and
then we are performing an aggregation
with our models as you can see here it
works in the same way as scikit-learn
works so your important methods you're
instantiating them with parameters and
you're running feed predict
and what are these models doing these
models actually taking an aggregation
and they are ordering the texts from the
easiest one by their like opinion of the
crowd to the hardest one by opinion of
the crowd and then assigning them some
score so the score will be one is it if
it's the hardest text ever and it will
be zero if it's like the easiest text
and here ground truth depicts like the
hardness level of the text from 0 to 12
so like for example 11 it's a very hard
text and if you see near noisy red
literary model gives it also a result
very close to one so crowd actually
performs the labeling very correct
and what do we have in this Library what
can you use which methods Which models
how to assess it now and start using it
immediately so there are aggregation
methods based on four types of data
categorical textual image and pairwise
you can see here the methods implemented
uh you can access them in GitHub and you
can try them like right away in the same
manner as you can try scikit-learn
there are data sets also in the same
manner as there are basic ones for
playing around with your proof of
conceptions in scikit-learn We Gather
them themselves onto Loca their
crowdsource data sets and you can read
the description and use them for your
tasks not only for like aggregating
something but also for some proven some
ideas some hypothesis related to machine
learning or else and there are also in
the same manner metrics which the
picture in the quality of aggregation
the quality of annotation and the
quality of overall result
so to bring it to the conclusion and
smoothly transition to maybe Q and A or
some discussion we have a crowd kit
which is based on the symbol same
principles of psychic learn of course
they are not equal because I can learn
is here exists for many years and it's a
very famous as far as I recall like 60
second package in the queue like of
popularity ever being downloaded and
we're just a small small thingy but
still uh it's based on the same
principles it's designed for using it
handfully in your machine learning
pipelines it's platform agnostic can be
used with any type of crowdsourced
annotations and it actually will happen
you to gather big high quality data sets
for machine learning here you can find
some links if somebody is interested to
look at the GitHub give some suggestions
give some comments we're super happy to
answer and to provide like explanations
how to use it and where to use it and
that's the end of my talk I was very
fast I think and I am super happy to
answer any questions super happy to
connect and just super happy to present
here today thank you very much
well thank you Virginia that was a very
very nice
uh talk and I really like the uh the
concepts and the motivation behind crop
kids so yes we have plenty of time to uh
for Q a and so those participating
in in chat right now feel free to feel
free to write your questions and I can
bring up a screen for Virginia to answer
if necessary
there's nothing so far let's just give
it a just a few more minutes while we're
waiting for the first question I was a
bit curious uh in terms of
um contributing to crowdkit in fact you
know uh where can we find sort of like
the documentation or guides for
contributing oh let me actually can I
send them in chat or maybe I can send
them to you and you can send them in
chats uh yes of course actually in fact
perhaps we can post about on on Discord
uh the link to to that you could share
it with me as well and I can and you can
send it whichever is most convenient
yeah that's exactly what I will do
um so but it's pretty much easy to find
because it's called crowdkit and it's
like the first Lincoln GitHub that you
will Google so I would say we made it
super easy there you go you build the
SEO
yes yes we we hacked Google
completely so I'm sending you the link
and I'm sending you a second link
because I have a plenty of links to send
excellent thank you
um and I will share them in uh in
Discord
thank you
and yes if anybody wants to contribute
or has some ideas where it can be like
improved or maybe is interested in some
data type which they have used for
example like audio because audio
annotation is used a lot in the voice
assistance for example your training
your media Alexa and you're gathering
this the like voice overs from a
crowdsourcing and then you're thinking
how to aggregate audio because it's a
very complex one we had ideas we had
some models for aggregation but we
didn't implement it yet because of the
like uh
we thought that it can be postponed but
maybe somebody is interested and it will
like speed us up so I'm like searching
for motivation here you know yeah yeah
yeah I think that that could be an
interesting use case for audio
crowdsourcing
um all right there is a question in in
chat I'll bring it up one screen and
I'll read it up
um so it's a question from uh in the
mirror is support for deep learning
Frameworks Keras python Etc coming or
already how we do that
uh
it's uh okay so it's a nice question uh
I really want to know where it's coming
from because it's definitely like a
person thinking how to apply these
aggregations in some deep learning
neural networks which is actually like a
case for example for convolutions or
something
uh I am as a machine learning engineer
in the past very happy for this question
but
um you don't need any support
technically because here you're just
getting your data
um maybe I understand it from the part
that you wanna for example have a result
your data in some pytorch format on in
some Keras format or like in the
tensorflows like in tensors
uh I am not sure that it can be done in
tensors considering that we're having
um this Panda structure because it's
very important to have these three
columns like a worker label and uh
object but I can think of somehow of
transferring these data types and make
them easier easily accessible for the
Deep learning neural networks but I
would say pretty much you already can
use it
so I I don't think there is like a much
support needed or if you see any ways
that you wanted to see it then please
contact us and we will think about it
yeah
yeah perhaps there's a link that
actually create like a data sets
um package a link between a crop kit and
a data sets like I remember uh hugging
face as a data sets package really sort
of inherited from tensorflow and
narrated from somewhere else as well so
great
um there is one more question
there we go
killing how would you aggregate say 50
limit results for one example and it is
a highly subjective yes or no question
could an average be done do you think
uh so
I mean it depends on which which data
type was labeled so was it like for
example as I was talking about the pay
and Rise comparisons they are very
subjective uh so it's like better or
worse uh
so I I won't take into the deep how
Bradley Terry works or like noisy
Bradley Terry which are models for
exactly uh these types of like
subjective answers uh but I I would
recommend to use in this case just in
general like um
so when you're working with
crowdsourcing you usually have some uh
knowledge about the people who are this
crowd you have some features which are
describing them and you can create a
trustworthy feature also
um so firstly pre-filtering of the
results should be based on the
transformance in the means that person
are actually thinking that and the
result is actually his honest opinion
and then
I would say an average
based expectation maximization algorithm
based on like some uh their
trustworthiness skills or average or
depends on the task I would say depends
on the task
but I am interested why 50 and I'm very
much interested which data type you
meant and if you have any like
particular task please come to me I will
be happy to discuss the particular case
thank you very much for the questions
guys
yeah oh yeah good questions to achillia
now encourage you to again post your
question on this card and reach out to
Virginia even if not via Discord via
other methods
that you mentioned earlier so
um
great we have time to field one more
question if anyone has any
uh
yeah and I definitely agree with the
comment about the Upstream of deep
learning that was a very right one thank
you very much I am in a very talk mood
so that's why I'm answering question not
with the three words but 33 but yes that
was a very nice memorization